when you became heavily addicted
especially after you relapsed and it was
serious I mean you almost died I think
that
when you're in so much pain that
the consequences don't matter to you
you're not thinking about
what could happen or what's going to
happen to you you're just in pain and
you're and you just want to escape or
numb out and so I put numbing out before
everything in my life and when I choose
drugs I'm choosing them over family over
friends over my career over
essentially everything and
um because of the way that I use because
it helps you destroy any emotion you're
going through yeah yeah I mean it
destroys every feeling and it it takes
away the bad feelings that you feel
inside all the pain all the trauma you
know it all stems from unresolved work
that
you know I hadn't done with my therapist
you know what freaked me out when I was
watching the documentary and and when
you OD'd and they put this tube in your
neck one of the consequences was you
could not see you had such a bad
overdose that it affected your vision
yeah so I still actually have vision
problems
um to this day like I don't drive I
don't drive anymore because I have blind
spots in my vision so like from the
overdose yes and it hasn't repaired
itself no it repaired like
significantly more
um within the first three months of the
overdose happening but then there was
residual and so like when I look at you
if I'm looking at your eyes I don't see
your nose or your mouth oh good can you
see my hair I can see your hair oh good
good look at that focal point yeah
um and it was due to the lack of oxygen
to my brain it killed off some cells
that just never repaired
um do you ever lay in bed at night and
go why the [__] did I do this to myself
I can't drive now and like you are you
angry with yourself
a lot of people ask me like do you have
any regrets in life and a lot of times I
start to answer like yeah I wish I
didn't overdose because it I have
hearing impairment I have Vision
impairment and like
I that was just an awful thing to put my
family and friends through
um but I also have to like real remember
the importance of not living in the past
and not having regrets for things yeah
um so I try to remain positive and have
like a healthy perspective on what
happened to me
and just stay in the present moment in
the documentary they said you were
drinking and doing weed and you felt
okay I can drink in moderation and do
weed and Elton says no Demi I'm sorry
but you cannot drink and do weed because
every habit especially some smokers will
go I could have one or two cigarettes a
day no you could buy by the end of the
year you'll be up to a pack right right
so so now you've stopped everything
because Elton was right oh you're
completely sober yeah so
um
I didn't stop everything because he's
right I had to learn it on my own right
and what happened was is I I was smoking
so much weed and taking Edibles
sometimes 300 milligrams at a time just
you know just an unhealthy level there's
like this thing called dabbing and I was
dabbing from the moment I woke up to the
moment I fell asleep and I all I did was
replace my addiction with something that
I thought was safer right and
um it just it threw me into this deep
depression where you know I put on a
bunch of weight because I wasn't because
I was just smoking and eating and
um I was hiding in my room not wanting
to go outside because I didn't want
anyone to see me
um and I could see you because of the
weight or yeah the weight and also just
like this profound
sadness that I felt because I wasn't
experiencing life you know what happened
was is I ultimately was in this walking
coma where I wasn't feeling any pain but
I also wasn't feeling any Joy right I
wasn't
now when I laugh and have belly laughs
and there's tears streaming down my face
like it feels so much more rewarding
than when I would
laugh while I was high and and I and I
don't I don't really know why that is
but I think it's just because I'm more
present
and those and smoking led me back to um
and drinking led me back to
other substances and so I ended up going
back into treatment in um November of
2021 and abstinence has been the key for
me
good